Here's some things I prepped to make my week just a little bit easier.
My kids wanted some goldfish,
so I prepped the dough for that
and popped that in the fridge while I prepped all of my other things.
Moved on to making some pancake dry mix
that I just have to mix with some eggs and milk
in the morning. And since my bananas weren't ripe,
I popped them in the oven for a few minutes
and then made some banana bread.
My kids love banana bread.
I don't know what it is about,
it's always gone the same or the very next day.
So I made a loaf of that before moving on to making some granola bars.
These are really simple to make by combining some peanut butter,
honey, oats,
some chocolate. I also added some cacao powder
and then put that in the fridge to chill
while I got started on my apple sauce.
I had an abundance of apples at home,
so this is one of my favorite things to do with them.
Cook them down with some water and a drizzle of maple syrup
until they were the texture I wanted them to be
before moving on to making some lemon grass meatballs.
I chopped up some mint lemon grass,
green onions, seasoned that up with some ginger garlic fish sauce,
roll them into little balls,
and then fried them off. Those were frying.
I started on a quick little salad that I Like,
to keep in the fridge to have.
This time around, I did some kale,
cucumbers, and some feta cheese,
made a simple lemon vinaigrette,
and then throughout the week,
I'll pair it with whatever I'm craving.
This point, I rolled out my goldfish dough
and laid all of my tiny little goldfish onto a baking tray,
and then pop them in the oven for about 10 minutes
before pulling them out. Like,
prepping at least one meal to have on hand.
So this week, it was Thai fried rice.
Lucky. And I have been loving fried rice lately,
so this was perfect. And then it was time to put everything away.
Started with my apple sauce,
my goldfish, my banana bread,
my Thai fried rice, my lemon grass meatballs,
kale salad that I prepped.
And then I cut up my granola bars that had been sitting in the fridge.
I like cutting them up so it makes it easier to grab them.
And this is everything we prepped.